painting is poetry that is seen rather
than felt and poetry is painting that is
felt rather than seen
a painter should begin every canvas with
a wash of black because all things in
nature are dark except where exposed by
the light
[Music]
simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication
study without desire spoils the memory
and it retains nothing that it takes in
[Music]
the painter has the universe in his mind
and hands
i love those who can smile in trouble
nothing can be loved or hated unless it
is first understood
[Music]
as a well-spent day brings happy sleep
so life well used brings happy death
[Music]
art is never finished only abandoned
learning never exhausts the mind
the knowledge of all things is possible
as you cannot do what you want want what
you can do
it is easier to resist at the beginning
than at the end
life without love is no life at all
all our knowledge has its origin in our
perceptions
he who thinks little airs much
realize that everything connects to
everything else
make your work to be in keeping with
your purpose
once you have tasted the taste of sky
you will forever look up
obstacles cannot crush me
every obstacle yields to stern resolve
[Music]
why does the eyes see more clearly when
asleep than the imagination when awake
learning is the only thing the mind
never exhausts never fears and never
regrets
a well-spent day brings happy sleep
wisdom is the daughter of experience
[Music]
he who truly knows has no occasion to
shout
a wave is never found alone but is
mingled with the other waves
just as a well-filled day brings blessed
sleep so well-employed life brings a
blessed death
in time and with water everything
changes
the noblest pleasure is the joy of
understanding tears come from the heart
and not from the brain
every action needs to be prompted by a
motive
[Music]
there is no object so large but that at
a great distance from the eye it does
not appear smaller than a smaller object
near
he who is fixed to a star does not
change his mind
[Music]
i have always felt it is my destiny to
build a machine that would allow man to
fly
poor is the pupil who does not surpass
his master
[Music]
one can have no smaller or greater
mastery than mastery of oneself
[Music]
you can have no dominion greater or less
than that over yourself
life well spent as long
there are three classes of people
those who see those who see when they
are shown those who do not see
you do ill if you praise but worse if
you censure what you do not understand
a beautiful body perishes but a work of
art dies not
beyond a doubt truth bears the same
relation to falsehood as light to
darkness
experience does not air only your
judgments heir by expecting from her
what is not in her power
[Music]
be a mirror absorb everything around you
and still remain the same
beauty perishes in life but is immortal
in art
[Music]
if your wife slept with another man she
has already sins and will no longer
return to being faithful
art lives from constraints and dies from
freedom
[Music]
while i thought that i was learning how
to live i have been learning how to die
[Music]
people reveal themselves completely only
when they are thrown out of the
customary conditions of their life
our life is made by the death of others
[Music]
not to appreciate life all of life is
not to deserve it
to discover the soul living in
somebody's body we watch the surrounding
of the body and if it's messy and
disordered so is the soul
you